The situation in Ukraine remains quite fluid.
A new government is forming.
We don’t yet know how much legitimacy, authority
it will have over the situation.
Violence has abated with the exception of
Crimea, but it will take a long time before
the dust settles and we have a good sense
as to whether a country that has really been
undergoing a great deal of uncertainty and
instability since the fall of the Soviet Union
is turning the corner and heading in a positive
direction.
There are three things to know, to keep in
mind, about the situation in Ukraine.
The first is that it’s a very complicated
country politically and ethnically.
Going back to the 14th century, the Polish,
the Lithuanians, the Austrians occupied large
chunks of Ukraine particularly in the west.
And that part of the country is therefore
oriented toward Europe.
People who live there tend to be ethnically
Ukrainian and speak Ukrainian as their mother
tongue.
The eastern part of the country has tended
to be under Russian domination.
There are many ethnic Russians.
The oblast, or states in the east, have a
population that is about 40 percent ethnic
Russian.
Crimea has a Russian majority -- almost 60
percent of its population is Russian.
They look to Russia.
They speak Russian.
They identify Ukraine as a country that is
quite attached to Russia.
And for this reason, finding a way to keep
the country together, trying to find policies
to bring the country into some kind of national
unity is going to be very difficult.
The second issue to keep an eye on is that
even though the last couple of weeks have
been quite remarkable -- in fact, almost a
miracle that this transition occurred as peacefully
as it did -- there is much hard work ahead.
Yanukovych did fall from power very quickly.
The state peeled away from him, turned against
him, including his own party, the Party of
Regions.
And we saw the police, the military, the bureaucracy
essentially throw their weight behind this
new government.
That’s quite remarkable, and quite positive.
But the country has a very weak institutional
infrastructure; it is on the verge of default.
It is not yet clear when the IMF, the US and
the EU will step forward.
It’s not clear whether Ukraine will be able
to make the political and economic reforms
necessary to get the loans to keep the country
fiscally afloat.
The third point to keep an eye on is the geopolitics.
Russia has always been an overlord for Ukraine,
including after the fall of the Soviet Union,
but this could be the moment at which Ukraine
finally emerges from Russia’s sphere of
influence.
Putin has been dealt a serious blow.
He picked Yanukovych.
Yanukovych is now on the run.
Putin wanted to build a Eurasian union with
Ukraine as Russia’s junior partner.
That no longer seems possible.
Ukraine has to be careful and has to balance
between ties to Europe and ties to Russia,
but this really could be a moment in which
finally Ukraine enjoys more autonomy and can
deepen its ties to Europe and chart a course
toward rule of law and liberal democracy.